- Hi everyone.
Welcome to the Homeroom live stream.
Sal Khan here.
Very exciting guest today.
We're gonna have Vivek Murthy,
former surgeon general
of the United States.
Obviously, there's a lot of
things to talk about health
and mental health related right now
in the world for better, for worse.
But before we get into that,
I will give my standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
And as we saw several guests ago
with the professor from Yale,
by donating to Khan Academy
not only will you be helping many people,
but you yourself will
become a happier person
that's what research tells us.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations
that have stepped up.
And I'm guessing they're
now happier organizations
because they have stepped
up to support Khan Academy
especially during COVID,
when we were already running a deficit
and our deficits grew,
and we continue to run deficits for 2021.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, Novartis,
and the many, many other
supporters of Khan Academy.
Last announcement, just a reminder
that you can get a version of
what you're hearing right now
as a podcast "Homeroom
with Sal" the podcast
wherever you get podcasts.
Now with that, I'm excited
to go into our conversation.
We have Vivek Murthy, the
former surgeon general
and now author of "Together".
The Healing Power of Human Connection
in a Sometimes Lonely World.
Vivek, thanks for joining us.
- Hey Sal, it's great to join you.
How are you today?
- I'm doing all right.
I mean, there's so much I
wanna talk to you about.
Maybe the first thing,
I mean, just the role surgeon general.
I remember when I was a kid,
and I remember that's what C. Everett Koop
was the surgeon general.
And he had the whole no smoking campaign
which was great, but I was just like,
is he a surgeon or is he a
general or is he neither?
(Vivek laughs)
So explain to folks what
the surgeon general is,
and why is it called surgeon general?
- Well, it's a great question.
So the surgeon general
is an individual in the US government
who has two roles.
One is to number one, provide the public
with the best information on health
so people can make good
decisions for their families.
And the other role is to lead
one of the uniformed
services in the US Government
called the US Public Health
Service Commissioned Corps.
And this is a group of about
6,600 uniformed officers,
doctors, nurses, physical therapists
and public health engineers and others,
who each and every day are
working in federal agencies
to strengthen public health
and also deploy during times of emergency
to help at tornadoes and
the aftermath of hurricanes.
We sent them to Liberia to
help with the ebola outbreak
a few years back.
And together, the surgeon general manages
these two responsibilities.
But it's because of the role
leading the Commissioned Corps,
one of our uniformed services,
that is actually why the
surgeon general wears a uniform.
And lastly, I'll tell you
that the surgeon general
is actually not a
general in terms of rank,
because the Public Health
Service Commissioned Corps
follows the Navy rank system.
So then sergeant general is
actually a three-star admiral
as opposed to a general per say.
- But they don't call
it the surgeon admiral.
it the surgeon admiral
and it turns out that you
don't have to be a surgeon
to be the surgeon general. (laughs)
In fact, most of the
recent surgeons general,
including myself, have been
either internal medicine doctors
or family medicine doctors.
There have been surgeons, Dr. Carmona
who is George W. Bush's surgeon general
was a trauma surgeon.
C Everett Koop was a pediatric surgeon.
- So with your former
role as surgeon general
and now this book that
you're writing, "Together"
and it seems like this touches
on kind of social-emotional wellbeing,
although I'll let you describe it.
I'm sure you can do a better job.
I mean, it seems like
one of your focus areas
really has been
not just on the traditional
physical health side of things
as surgeon general,
but also in the mental.
I mean, well actually I
don't wanna speak for you.
What have been your priorities
when you were surgeon general
and now what type of change
or information are you
trying to get out there?
- Well, you know, when I
was surgeon general, Sal,
I began my time in office
with a listening tour
where I just spend time
traveling around the country,
asking people how I could help.
And the issues that I heard from them
were consistent with what we
are hearing and seeing a lot.
And later what I was seeing
in the hospital as a doctor
which is that the fundamental problem
that we have with the opioid epidemic
was affecting communities
all across the country.
The emerging challenge with
e-cigarettes at that time
was also presenting a great
challenge in terms of,
you know, clawing back in
fact some of the progress
we had made on tobacco and smoking.
And so I focus a lot on those
but the issue around mental health
and particularly around
loneliness and social connection
came about in part because
of these early conversations.
And because I realized that
behind so many of the
stories I was hearing,
stories around chronic
illness, around depression,
around addiction were
these threads of loneliness
where people would often say to me,
"You know, I feel I have
to carry all these burdens
in my life by myself.
Or I feel if I disappeared tomorrow,
nobody would even care,
they wouldn't even notice."
People felt invisible.
And it wasn't just the
people we stereotypically
think of as lonely, perhaps
the older individual
who's living at home by themselves.
But I was hearing this
from college students, Sal
who were surrounded by
thousands of other students
on campus but still felt profoundly alone.
I was hearing this from moms and dads
in neighborhoods where they
were connected to the school,
connected to their neighbors
but still didn't quite
feel like there was anybody
that they could truly confide in,
anyone who truly got
them and understood them.
And so on it went whether
I was talking to CEOs
or nurses and doctors
or even members of Congress themselves.
I came to realize that loneliness
and this feeling of being isolated
is extraordinarily common.
And it turns out it has profound impacts
and implications for our
physical and mental health.
- That's fascinating.
And I wanna encourage everyone watching
put your questions on Facebook or YouTube.
I'll surface as many of them
as we can to Dr. Murthy.
But you know, on this
question of loneliness,
we've had other guests,
who've talked about trends,
social media making at least
young people feel more anxious
or in many cases depressed.
Is this in your mind a new phenomenon
or has it always been there
and we're just finally unpacking it?
This loneliness phenomenon especially.
- Well, loneliness has
been with us for ages,
for centuries.
And I mean, interestingly,
if you look back
in the literature at
least in Western culture,
Shakespeare was actually
one of the first people
to actually talk
explicitly about loneliness
in his work or to reference it.
But people have been feeling lonely
for thousands of years.
But there are a couple of
things that are different now.
I think one is that we,
unlike times in past
where we tended to live in
the same place that we grew up
where we tended to have
generations upon generations,
living in close proximity
and often living in the same household,
we are living in a very
different society now.
One that is relatively new in
the history of civilization,
where we are more mobile,
where we don't necessarily live
in extended family networks.
And the overlay of technology on that
has been a mixed blessing.
While it allows us to connect deeply
with people and to stay
in touch with people
we may not otherwise be
allowed to see as easily,
we also find that the way in
which we're using technology
often displaces our in-person connection
or dilutes our in-person conversations
as we bring our devices, for
example, to the dinner table
or we allow ourselves to be on them
when we're catching up with friends.
And then finally, there's
one last piece here
that I worry about Sal,
which is I think there's an element
around how our current culture
augmented by technology
but independent of that,
how it actually contributes
to people's sense of self
and to their own wellbeing.
And what I worry about Sal
is I think that for many of
our young people in particular
but really for all of us.
What our culture tells us
is that we have meaning, we
have worth as human beings,
if we're successful.
And we're successful, if we can
acquire one of three things,
wealth, power or fame.
And if we acquire those
then we were held up as success stories.
And those are the people
we read about in the paper.
Those are the people whose
biographies are lauded.
Those are the people
who are seen as heroes.
But the message that we
send to everyone in society
is that if you're not
wealthy, powerful or famous,
that you are not as worthy.
And that is a fundamental problem
because I think our fundamental
worth as human beings,
is not extrinsic, it's intrinsic.
It comes from our ability
to give and to receive
love, compassion and kindness.
And that's something we're born with.
It's something I see my four year old
and my two year old
doing each and every day
because that's what kids do,
that's how we're born into the world.
But we forget it, other things
get layered on top of it
we come to believe
that if we're kind we'll
get taken advantage of.
That the world's a harsh place
and that we need to pursue
these other objectives
like work, wealth and
power to have meaning.
And that's a challenge
that's a particular
feature of modern society.
- And is there anything
we can do about it?
I mean, you know, we can hope
that people somehow start profiling folks
who have really content
family lives and all of that.
But I don't think, you
know, TMZ is about to change
or People Magazine is about
to change their coverage.
Look at this really
content father of four.
You've never heard of
him but he's very happy.
How do we change this?
I mean, if you can't change culture
are there tools that we can do
to mitigate the negative impacts?
- Well this is what I actually
found very encouraging
about this topic, Sal
is that you might think
loneliness hmm that
sounds kind of depressing.
It turns out though,
that the reason I think
this is profoundly inspiring
and hopeful area is because
the opposite of loneliness,
which is social connection
is something that we
are hardwired to pursue
and to build into our lives.
We feel better, frankly
when we're together.
We feel safer when we're together.
It doesn't mean we're all extroverts
but what it means is that we all need
some degree of social connection,
we're better off for it.
And because we are hardwired in that way,
it turns out that even a little bit
of meaningful social interaction
can actually make us
feel profoundly better
for a long period of time.
So just think for a moment
about the last time perhaps
you were in the grocery store
or in a coffee shop and
you passed on a kind word
to the person at the cash register.
Or when they actually
asked how you were doing
and then paused to listen
to what the answer was.
You know, those are moments
which make us feel good
because they make us feel seen and heard.
And they can land that feeling of...
Feeling seen and heard can
last with us for hours.
Similarly, when you
have a friend who calls.
Let's say unexpectedly you get
a call from your best friend
and you have a five or
10 minute conversation,
that can lead you to feeling great
for a long period of time.
So the way we rebuild connected lives,
the way we recenter
ourselves around a culture
that recognizes our worth is intrinsic
and grounded in our ability
to give and receive love,
is we do that by leading by example.
We do that by allowing ourselves
to in small ways initially,
reach out to people and enjoy the fruits
of human connection.
And here's some simple ways we can do it.
So like first for example,
we can keep 15 minutes
a day aside to reach out to
and connect with people we care about.
It could be a phone call
or a video conference call.
It could be writing to
somebody that we love saying,
"Hey, I'm just thinking of you
and I wanna know how you are."
Second thing we can do
is we can make the time we
have with people really count
by improving the quality of it.
And the way we do that most readily
is by eliminating distraction
when we're talking to others.
That's our cell phone, that's our computer
if we have a tendency to check email
or the news while we're on the phone.
And the third thing we can
do is seek each other out.
Looking to serve one another.
It turns out Sal from
ourselves to the other person.
And we also reinforce to
ourselves and remind ourselves
that we have value to bring to the world.
And this is so important, Sal
because when people become
lonely for a long period of time,
what happens is they lose faith
that they actually have any
value to bring to the world.
They start to feel that they're lonely
'cause they're not likable.
And they also find that their focus
ends up being excessively on themselves
because they're worried
fundamentally about safety,
which is what we all
worry about unconsciously
when we're lonely.
- Yeah
No, that makes a ton of sense.
And I mean, there's two
things that I just heard.
Because when you kind
of reach out to someone
and especially show
gratitude towards them,
and this gels with our conversation
we had a couple of days
ago, actually last week
about the science of how
to be a happy person.
You know, not only do you show that person
that you see them, you appreciate them.
They feel less lonely,
they feel more safe.
But there's good research
that it makes you happier
when you show that gratitude
towards other people.
You know, question for you.
You are accomplished in all
of the very traditional ways
that we just mentioned that
we shouldn't highlight people
(Sal laughs)
But you are accomplished in those ways.
What do you do to not lose your balance?
You know, I'm sure when you
were part of the administration,
you saw a lot of classically type A people
who are work, work, work work.
Probably not taking the 15 minutes
to kind of call up their cousin and say,
"Hey, how are you doing?
What do you do?
And how do you coach people
to try to balance things
a little bit more?
- Well, it's a great question, Sal.
And let me tell you that
I stand here before you
as somebody who has not done
that well for much of my life.
And in fact one of my motivations
to work on this subject area,
one of the reasons I was compelled
to go into it was because myself
was experiencing a deep
well of loneliness.
And it was very painful.
And I felt that not only during childhood
which was a real challenge
for me in elementary school
but even during adulthood
when I was surgeon general
and actually in the few
years that followed it.
And what I realized I had done, Sal
is I had always prioritized
and cared about the people in my life.
They were always you know,
from a stated perspective,
my top concerns.
But the way I was actually
living my lifestyle
was not consistent with
those priorities, right?
So there was a gap between
my stated priorities
and my living priorities.
Work was actually my top priority.
And I came out of my time in government,
after serving as surgeon
general for a few years,
what I realized
is that in an effort to
focus wholly on work,
thinking hey, I don't know how
much time I have in office.
I wanna get as much done as I can.
And you know, contribute as much as I can
to the public health.
I made a critical mistake,
which is that I assumed
that I would be better able to do that
if I gave all of my time,
including that time
that I spent with family
and with friends.
And it turned that that hurt
me, like in the long run.
It probably reduced how
much I could actually give
to the job because it meant
that I was cutting myself off
from one of the most important sources
of fuel that we have in our lives.
And that is our relationships
with one another.
So here's what I do now.
Now, when a friend calls,
I pick up the phone,
even if it's just for 10 seconds to say,
"Hey, can I call you later?"
Because just hearing
their voice is powerful.
And is much more powerful
than declining the call
and then sending them a text later saying,
"Hey, can I call you back?"
The second thing that I do is
I create space in my life now
that is free from
distraction and technology.
Often that's dinner time with the family
and bedtime when me and my wife
are putting our two children to bed.
And it's time where we're
just focused on each other.
And the third thing
that I'll mention to you
is something that I formed
in my life called a moai.
And a moai is something I
write about in the book.
It's a Japanese concept
actually that began in Okinawa
many, many generations ago.
But the idea is that
they would take a group
of young children, put
them together and say,
"Now you are a group, you are a moai
and you are responsible for each other.
You have to look out for each other."
And so they were making
an explicit commitment
to one another to be there for each other.
And what I realized in 2018,
when I was at a fellowship
retreat with two close friends
who I love dearly but rarely ever see
is I realized that as lonely
as we were all feeling
that we would not end
up truly reconnecting
in the way that we needed
unless we made an explicit commitment.
So we said to each other,
why don't we form a moai?
The commitments we'll make is once a month
we'll video conference with each other.
We'll make it a point to
be real with one another,
to talk about this stuff that matters
especially the things that
we don't talk about often
with our friends,
our relationships, our
finances and our health.
And we also made it a point to say
if something comes up
in between those calls
we're gonna reach out to each other.
We're gonna have a text thread
and we'll just ping each other.
And we can just get on the
phone for five minutes,
you know, to talk through
a difficult situation
we'll do that but we'll make a commitment
to be there for one another.
And in the last two years, Sal
that moai has changed my life.
It has been an incredibly
important anchor for me.
And my two moai brothers, Sunny and Dave
we helped each other
through so many challenges
over the last few years.
It wasn't that we weren't
friends before that
but the difference, Sal
was in taking these implicit
commitments around friendship
and making them explicit.
And that made all the difference.
- I love that.
I'm not joking.
I think I'm already making the list
of who are the two or three
people I need to join my moai.
Because, you know, I'll share my own side.
You know, I couldn't agree with you more
about this delusion that many folks have
that if you're already working 40 hours
that you're gonna be able to
do your job that much better
if you go to 50, 60, 70, 80 hours.
It's just going to deplete you.
I remember the first job I
had out of business school,
it was at a hedge fund
and I was ready to...
I thought I would have
to work 70 or 80 hours.
And my boss, it was
only a two person firm.
He said, "Sal, our job
is to make good decisions
not a bunch of bad decisions.
So go home, don't think about work,
connect with your family."
And this was before, you know,
I had just gotten married.
I didn't have kids at the time
but that's what gave me the time and space
to actually tutor Nadia
and that led to all of Khan Academy.
But more importantly,
it actually did balance me out.
And so I never forgot what Dan, Dan Wohl
it was called Wohl Capital did then.
And then I would say about five years ago
you know, various stresses just
started to really get to me.
And I started getting
claustrophobic in planes.
And that's when I started, you know,
just going down a similar journey
although I'm learning
a lot from your journey
of investing.
That's when I started meditating regularly
that's been transformational for me.
And I didn't do a moai.
I think I still need a moai
but last year I started getting a group
of broader friend circle of friends.
We used to meet in the park
but now we meet over video conference
every week where we
discuss things about life.
So there'll be a topic around parenting
or tough love or perception versus reality
but we'll dig into, you
know, what makes us tick.
And there are these double
or triple click conversations
versus what you normally
have at a gathering.
But I really liked the moai concept
with like a smaller group
that you really are family in
the best sense of the word.
(Khan laughs)
- Yeah, 'cause Sal I'll tell you
what really makes a difference here
like in whether people
feel lonely or connected
is really the quality
of those connections.
And the thing is all of us,
regardless of where we grew
up, what culture we're in
or how old we are, we all
have three coordinates.
We want to be seen and
understood for who we are,
we want to know that we matter
and we want to be loved.
Right that is true of all of us.
And the thing is when you
can be in a relationship
with someone, a friendship,
a romantic relationship
where you feel like you
can show up as who you are.
You don't have to put on errors,
you can truly be yourself,
that's extraordinarily powerful.
And you know, one of the great ways
that we can actually create and experience
that kind of connection
is actually by listening.
And I mentioned this because
so much of our emphasis
in modern day society is on action, right?
We have a friend who has a problem
we're thinking, okay,
boom how can I fix it?
We've had somebody else who's
not even a friend, a stranger
you know, who raises a concern
or says something wrong.
We wanna know, okay,
how can we correct them?
How can we get them the right answer?
We're very action oriented.
But in that, sometimes what gets lost
is the power of listening.
And when we're able to be
fully present with someone,
when we're able to give them
the gift of our full attention,
when they are able to then share
and be open with us,
that's an extraordinarily
powerful experience.
And what we tell somebody
when we listen deeply to them
is we tell them, I see
you, I understand you,
you matter and you are loved.
And that's why listening
is one of the most powerful
forces we have in forging
strong connection.
- No, I love that.
It's super, super powerful.
Again, you're exactly
right, you're exactly right.
It doesn't seem like action
in the traditional sense
but it actually often times leads
to a much deeper relationship
than any form of action
and actually, you know, better outcomes.
There's a ton of questions.
I've been monopolizing
you with all of mine
and I have many more.
But obviously as former surgeon general
we're in the middle of a pandemic.
I think everyone is super well versed.
You know, we had Dr. Fauci on here on
when we might get a vaccine
and the various therapy.
So I think folks know about that
although, I'm curious if
you have any perspectives
that you haven't heard.
But you know, there's a
question here from Facebook
for Christopher McDade.
With this pandemic,
it's affected a lot of
people's mental health.
How would you recommend dealing with this
now that we are isolating ourselves?
It goes back to the everything
we've been talking about.
Loneliness is one thing
but also depression and other
issues can be exacerbated.
What are your views there?
- Well first of all I wanna
thank him for his question.
I mean, that's absolutely right.
I think many people are struggling more
during this pandemic.
You know, keep in mind
human connection is healing.
and in a time of great
stress what we typically do
is we seek out more connection.
We pick up the phone and call a friend.
We go visit someone we care about.
And the fact that we can't do that now
I think has exacerbated that stress.
It's why you see high levels
of depression and anxiety.
It's why you see actually opioid overdoses
and alcohol use also on the rise.
But I do think that in this moment,
we can actually find healing once again
in social connection.
We just have to look for it
in a slightly different way.
So even though we can't for
example, go and visit a friend
or get together you know, for dinner
at a crowded restaurant
the same way we used to,
we can actually see friends
in safe ways, outside.
For example, if we're getting
together and wear masks
and we're distanced from our
friends and we're outdoors.
You know, we can create safe spaces
to interact with one another.
The other thing we can do
is to keep in mind some of these ideas
that Sal and I were talking about earlier.
Around 15 minutes a day keeping
that to re interact with
and to reach out to people you care about.
Making sure you make that
quality of the time count
by eliminating distraction.
Looking for ways to help
people in your network
whether that's a neighbor
who might be struggling because
they're worried to go to the grocery store
or a coworker who might
be having a hard time
teleworking and homeschooling their child.
And maybe you just dropping off some food
will make all the difference.
These are small but powerful ways to serve
that can actually help boost our mood
as well as strengthen our connection.
So the last thing I'll just mention here
because it's counterintuitive
is actually the importance of solitude.
And you might think,
gosh if you're looking
for human connection,
why solitude important?
Isn't that the opposite?
Isn't that being alone?
Well, solitude is about
being physically alone
but it's actually a
state of calm aloneness
and joyful aloneness.
And it's very different from loneliness
which is a subjective state
where I feel pained about
my lack of connection.
And I feel the connections I need
are greater than the connections I have.
And the reason we all need
some solitude in our lives,
the reason we have to actually recapture
our ability to be comfortable
being alone for some periods of time
is because it is in
those moments of solitude
that we allow the noise
around us to settle.
It's when we recenter
and reground ourselves.
It's when we reflect.
And when we allow ourselves
to just be in a world
that is constantly
moving faster and faster.
And when we can approach other people
from a place of being more
grounded and more centered.
We're more able to listen deeply to them.
We're more able to be present ourselves
and to share ourselves rather
than constantly worrying
about what the other person is saying.
You know, I say this
knowing that for many people
that finding an hour or
two to meditate every day
for example, might be way too much time.
But solitude can come in many
shapes and forms and sizes.
It can look like meditation.
It can look like just
time where you're sitting
on your front porch
and letting the breeze
blow against your face.
It could be a walk in nature.
It could be time in prayer.
It could be time spent listening to music
that soothes you.
But whatever it is and
for however long it is,
we need those times of solitude.
You know, I'll leave you with this wisdom
from my nephrology
professor in medical school.
This is one of my dearest mentors.
Her name is Dr. Peggy Bia.
And when I used to think I'm too busy,
you know to create time
for solitude in my life,
I would think of her.
'Cause she was a busy mom,
teacher, doctor and
hospital administrator.
But what she would do
even though she didn't have
much in the way of time,
was recognizing how important
those moments of solitude were.
Whenever she was about to
walk into a patient's room,
she would go to the
sink to wash her hands.
And for 20 seconds
she would just allow that warm
water to run over her hands.
And she would take a deep breath
and she would remember what
she had to be grateful for
that day.
Maybe it was the hug
that her kids gave her
when she was leaving the house.
Maybe it was a medical student
for whom an idea finally clicked
when she was teaching him that morning.
Maybe it was the
opportunity to participate
in the care of the patient
whose room she was about to walk into.
And then taking another deep breath
she would turn the
water off, dry her hands
and walk into that patient's room
feeling more grounded, more centered
more clear about who she
wanted to be than before.
And that is the power of
20 seconds of solitude.
And we all have 20 seconds in our life
but it's important for us is to remember
that power of that solitude.
And moments like this
when the world is turning around so fast,
when there's so much uncertainty
we need to anchor ourselves.
And moments of solitude, our
relationships with one another
are some of our most powerful anchors.
- Vivek, I gotta tell you,
you have a future in guided meditation.
Like I could just take snippets (laughs)
of what you just said
and I was feeling it.
I'm not kidding.
I think there's something very powerful
in even just your answer itself.
About you're right.
I felt that warm water over my hands
and I was like yes I have
to feel the gratitude.
But you're so right.
You know a lot of people
think that I'm extroverted
'cause I can sometimes appear
but I'm very much an introvert.
The notion is where you get your energy
and I need that solitude
but you're exactly right.
Solitude versus loneliness
are not the same thing.
You could be lonely in
a crowd as you said,
on a college campus, in a room at a party,
you can feel very lonely.
In fact, that's often
when I feel the loneliness
the most lonely versus when I'm alone
or when I'm with a very
small group of folks
but it's a super powerful idea.
You know, just one more question.
I know we're limited on time.
There's so much to talk about here.
Facebook, Michael Graves,
how profoundly does
rejection in a general sense
affect one's loneliness slash depression?
Is there a way to mitigate the feeling?
- Well, I think rejection is
so powerful and so damaging
because it gets at the core
of whether we have worth as human beings.
When we feel rejected,
what we're hearing from someone else
is that you don't have value,
that you're not worthy.
And this is especially
challenging for young people
whose identity is developing.
Now, this doesn't mean that we, you know,
can go through life and
figure out how to deal
with disappointment, right?
But there's a difference
between disappointment
and feeling rejected, right?
Disappointment is you know,
I wanted something to
work on in a certain way
and it didn't.
Feeling rejected is feeling,
gosh, I'm not worthy.
I'm not valuable.
That's what, you know, the
situation is telling me.
And we, I think can raise our children
to deal with disappointment.
But what we have to do
what's so important for all of us,
whether we're about kids or adults,
is to know where our worth
fundamentally comes from.
'Cause that should be a deep root
that we cultivate and build and nurture
over the course of our lives.
It should be a root that's
not shaken by circumstance.
And we all have challenges.
Like I struggle with
my own self-worth a lot
and have over many years.
It's a constant effort
for me to remind myself
during low points in my life
where my value truly comes from.
But this is actually where
friendship is so important
'cause when I was in
college and I asked somebody
actually a college classmates
on of these late night
philosophical conversations
that you tend to have in college.
I said, "Hey, what do
you think a friend is?"
And he paused for a moment
and he said, "A friend is
someone who reminds you
of who you are when you forget."
And I've always remembered
that definition over the years
that a friend is someone who reminds you
of who you are when you forget.
Because we all need mirrors like that.
People who can show us not
just who we think we are
but who we truly are.
Who can remind us of what
we bring to the world
that's so special.
Maybe it's our humor.
Maybe it's our insight.
Maybe it's our compassion or a kindness.
Maybe it's all of those things
but we need those reminders.
You know, Sal I'll just say, you know,
that this whole topic
that we've been discussing
this subject around
connection and mental health
and loneliness.
This whole book that I
wrote on the subject.
While ostensibly this is
about the topic of connection,
what it's truly about and
what I came to realize
toward the end of this writing
is it's really about love.
It's about the question
of how do we build lives
and truly a society that's more grounded
in human connection but really in love?
Because the two forces
that are fundamentally
driving us in our actions
and you can see this
on display in the world
are love and fear.
And the fear manifests a lot as anger,
as insecurity, as jealousy, as rage.
But we see the love manifesting as well
as kindness, as compassion,
as generosity, as concern.
But all of us have the ability
and the capacity to be
driven by love or fear.
And the question that I
think about most often
when I look at my own kids
and I think about what the
world will look like for them,
is I think that the world will
be more hospitable to them.
More encouraging, more
supportive, more nurturing
if you and I and everyone out there
does what we can to tip
the balance in the world
away from fear and toward love.
And to do that by the
words we choose to speak,
by how we treat other people,
by the issues we choose to work on
as well as the topics that we
choose to raise our voice on
and stand up for in the public square.
That's fundamentally what this is about.
And when I forget, you know, at times
just how powerful that love can be.
What I think about is
this ten second exercise
that Fred Rogers actually
he was famous for doing
during his talks.
And if you have 10 seconds,
I'll just walk you and our
listeners through it right now.
If you take your hand
and you just put it on your
heart and you close your eyes
and take a deep breath.
And just think about
the people in your life
who have been there for you
during your highs and your lows.
Think about the people
who have supported you,
who have taken care of you,
who have listened to you,
who have understood you even
at times when you weren't sure
if you were worthy of friendship and love.
Think about the people you turn to
in moments of pain and in moments of joy.
And feel their love just washing over you
filling you with peace,
filling you with happiness,
filling you with joy and open your eyes.
And what you felt in those 10 seconds.
That was the power of love.
And that love is most directly experienced
through our relationships
with other people.
And as a doctor who has
written prescriptions
for many, many medicines over the years.
Some incredibly powerful ones
that are the result of amazing science.
I will tell you that there
is no force more powerful.
There is no medicine that
is more healing than love.
And we all have the ability
to heal because we all
have the ability to love.
You don't need an MD or
an RN behind your name
in order to participate
in that healing process
that I think is at the heart
of what we need to do right now
to help strengthen our
families, our communities
and ultimately our world.
- Well thank you for, I mean,
that was incredibly powerful.
I don't wanna ruin what you just said.
I mean, you should just
drop the mic at that point
because there's so much in there.
But I think what's powerful
about what you just said
and even the exercise is you'll
hear even in cheesy movies
love is what runs the universe or whatever
but you're like, what do they really mean?
But I think your definition
of it is a very tangible one.
And it actually it was a bit of an aha
that you are right.
At the end of the day,
almost every action is
really driven by love.
Every thought is really
driven by either love or fear.
And that even when you said that,
I started thinking about
some of my own thoughts
or my own actions
and immediately I started
being able to classify them.
No that's a fear one, that's a love one.
And maybe that fear one, I
should do something different
because that's not a great motivation.
What you're saying is so powerful.
You should be the meditation
general or something like that.
(Sal laughs)
And maybe a future administration
they will introduce
some type of mindfulness for the country.
I'm not joking, I wasn't kidding
even that last exercise
you're really good at this.
And I think you're good at it
because it comes from a
place of genuine authenticity
and love which is a very,
very powerful thing.
So, you know, Vivek, thanks so much.
I know we're all out of time.
We went actually way over time.
This was really powerful
but thanks so much for this.
And I encourage everyone
to check out "Together"
and just try to figure out
ways to lead a healthier,
more robust, together, less lonely life.
- Well, thanks so much Sal.
It was so nice to be with you
and thanks for your
interest in this subject
and for everything you're doing
to help support families
who are in this time.
I must tell you and I wanna
encourage all of your listeners
to support Khan Academy and
to contribute what you can.
And, you know, I'm a beneficiary myself
because my two kids
they love Khan Academy,
especially Khan Academy Kids.
And they're constantly
asking if they can be on it.
So you've provided a reward for our kids.
So now if we want them to brush
their teeth or take a bath
we say, "Okay, you can
watch Khan Academy kids
for a few minutes, if
you brush your teeth."
So thank you Sal for the
parenting help. (laughs)
- Good to hear that.
No, thank you so much.
- Of course.
Take care then, be well.
- See you.
Well thanks everyone for joining.
Yeah, that was a great conversation.
And I wasn't joking with Vivek
that he should do some
whatever you wanna call them
meditations or guided whatever.
But I thought not only did he
have some really good insights
about I think a very important issue
that goes way overlooked for most of us,
but also very tangible
ways of working through it.
So thanks for joining
the next of our live
stream is going to be...
We're gonna have not as good of a guest.
It's going to be me. (laughs)
You can ask me anything.
So see you tomorrow at noon, pacific time.
Talk to you later.